Lawrence Kohlberg theory claims that our
development of moral reasoning happens
in six stages the stages themselves are
structured in three levels pre
conventional conventional and post
conventional to understand this better
imagine a conflict at school there is a
fight in the schoolyard
two ninth graders are beating up Tom
those who watch the fight are at
different stages of moral development
let's see what they do and how they
justify their behavior at Stage one we
make moral judgments based on obedience
and Punishment Phin sense of good or bad
is directly linked to whether he gets
punished or not finn sees what is
happening to his friend and wants to
help but he doesn't because he is afraid
the teacher may punish him if he gets
caught fighting he asks himself how can
I avoid punishment at Stage two we are
motivated by self-interest Mary decides
to intervene and help Tom she knows that
she might get punished but she also
knows that she could become a victim
herself someday if she helps Tom now he
might help her in the future she is
asking herself what's in it for me at
Stage three interpersonal Accord and
conformity guide our moral judgment
Betty sees the fight and wants to
intervene but when she realizes that all
the others are just watching she decides
not to get involved she wants others to
see that she is a good girl who is
conforming with the ethics of the
community she asks herself what do
others think of me at Stage four
we value Authority and want to maintain
social order when the teacher sees the
group fighting he immediately steps in
and shouts stop fighting at school is
forbidden he feels that above all it is
important to follow the rules otherwise
chaos breaks out he feels it is his duty
to uphold the rules that sustain a
functioning society he asks himself
can I maintain law and order at Stage
five
we understand rules as a social contract
as opposed to a strict order Jessie who
watches from afar is not sure how she
feels about this to her rules make sense
only if they serve the right purpose
obviously the school rules prohibit
fighting but maybe Tom deserves to
finally learn his lesson just yesterday
he punched a young girl from grade one
she asks herself does a rule truly serve
all members of the community at stage
six we are guided by universal ethical
principles all those involved now have
to face the headmaster he first explains
the school rules and why they exist
he then clarifies that rules are valid
only if they are grounded in justice the
commitment to justice carries with it an
obligation to disobey unjust rules the
Headmaster's highest moral principle is
compassion he believes that all people
should learn to understand each other's
viewpoints and that they don't feel
alone with their feelings he asks what
are the abstract ethical principles that
serve my understandings of justice at
the preconventional level finn is driven
by fear and marry by self-interest both
judge what is right or wrong by the
direct consequences they expect for
themselves and not by social norms this
form of reasoning is common among
children at the conventional level
Betty responds to peer pressure and the
teacher follows the rules their morality
is centered around what society regards
as right at this level the fairness of
rules is seldom questioned it is common
to think like this during adolescence
and adulthood
at the post conventional level Jesse
knows that things are complicated
because individuals may disobey rules
inconsistent with their own morality the
headmaster follows a universal ethical
idea at complete disconnect with what
society thinks or the rules say to him
everything is solved through compassion
the right behavior in his opinion is
therefore never a means to an end but
always an end in itself not every person
reaches this level the American
psychologist Lawrence Kohlberg based his
work on piaces theory of cognitive
development in order to confirm his
theory of stages of moral development
Kohlberg interviewed boys between the
ages of 10 and 16 he analyzed how they
would justify their decision when
confronted with different hypothetical
moral dilemmas we will now present to
you the most famous moral dilemma
Kohlberg presented to his students let's
see what you would do the Heinz dilemma
a woman was on her deathbed
there was only one drug that the doctors
thought might save her the druggist that
made that particular medicine sold it
for ten times the price of the
production costs the sick woman's
husband Heinz was poor and could not
afford to buy the drug not even with the
financial help of his friends Heinz then
asked the pharmacist to sell it to him
for half the price but he refused
to save the life of his wife Hines broke
into the man's laboratory and stole the
medicine
now tell us should Hines have stolen the
drug would it change anything if Hines
didn't love his wife what if the person
dying was not his wife but a stranger
should the police arrest the druggist
for murder if the wife had died please
write your answers and their
justifications in the comments below
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects and simple language and
cartoons to support students all around
the world in their learning if you want
to support us you can go to WWII and
calm sprouts and donate just $1 from
many fans makes a big difference
you